the first celebrity on the new season of
Dancing with the Stars come on out bindi
irwin yep the crocodile hunter's
daughter is all grown up and joining
Dancing with the Stars I'm really really
excited and so honored to be a part of
this new journey a new chapter of my
life I have to tell you this is
completely different to anything I've
ever used to wrangling croc it out bindi
is going from the outback to the
ballroom this fall becoming dancing with
the stars at first season 21 cast member
wen et caught up with the
seventeen-year-old earlier this year she
told us she was ready for new Hollywood
adventures mostly to keep her father's
legacy alive I think that what I'm
passionate about is wildlife and
conservation so I've dedicated my life
to being a wildlife warrior and so I
think that through filming work it's a
great platform to be able to spread my
message to a wider audience so I think
that I just like to carry on in dad's
footsteps dancing with the stars at 21st
season kicks off September 14